if you want to be successful learn from
the other people's mistakes don't learn
from the successful stories don't hate
your competitors respect your
competitors learn from him I complain a
lot when I was young because I think
Bill Gates took odd opportunities for
the Microsoft and Steve Jobs all these
guys there's no job there's no great big
stuff left for us need motivation watch
a top 10 would believe nation what's up
at seven my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have an
amazing gift inside you that I want to
see explode out onto the world so let's
get your motivation to attend and get
you believing in you grab a snack and
chew on today's lessons from a man who
went from growing up in China and giving
tours to tourists for free for nine
years just to learn English to becoming
one of the wealthiest people in the
world with a net worth of over fifty
billion dollars he's Jack Ma and here's
my take on his top ten R was a success
vol 3 enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one learn from the mistakes of
others my thinking is that you guys
remember if you want to be successful
learn from the other people's mistakes
don't learn from the successful stories
successful stories they make don't
listen to that there are a lot of
reasons behind it just like god I
remember the first time Harvard Business
School came to us say J we want to write
a case study for you
yes years 2001 a 2000 became the spend
one week and they write a report and I
read no I said this is not me and this
is this is you as a no this is not us is
that this is you so they make IV sign
and the case study go up and they start
to teaching love universities the next
five years they invite to need to go to
the case study and they always find a
competitor of my company and F after
every case that case study Ali Papa
would die that company will succeed all
the students are Greek and actually
every five year all the competitive diet
ways to survive so how can you study
this kind of a success of a star
learn from the mistakes the other people
no matter how smart you are you will
encounter these mistakes you learn from
mistakes not because you will be able to
avoid mistakes you were able to when
these mistakes come they suffer comes
you know how to deal with it how to face
it I like the book I want to write if I
if I want if I can is a re Bubber 1001
mistake this is the most rational things
that in my life in my life is not how
much we achieved is how much we go
through the tough days and mistakes and
this is what you speak if you start to
think now would be good rule number 2
focus on quality not size last a century
the bigger the better this century the
good abandon do the business not because
the size it is not necessary the big
size you are the more profit you are you
really believe that I believe that's a
different we have you know we got a
fortune 500 companies you you judge
because of the size how many of them are
really happy how many of them profit no
small companies they're very profitable
they're very happy because spend time
was the wife and a husband and kids
traveling around and first life rule
number three be the first dog tried to
beat the best
be the first be the first to change be
the first the chap take the challenge be
the first one to overcome the
difficulties because the best person
there's only one Olympic champion I
don't think I'm lucky enough to be bad
but I can always try the new things and
don't give I believe it because you you
are so unique everybody's unique be
yourself is always the key rule number
four prepare for the future people like
me I was born in a very poor family I
never got a great education and I failed
all the examinations for what reason I
don't know but later I realize I don't
have money I don't have technology I
don't have a lot of good backgrounds
where we have a rich uncle or something
no they only that competed with my
people then young people is let's
compete for ten years later this is what
I believe ten years later will be
happening so everything I do for that
goal
I know 10 years later this thing is
going to happen so prepare for that
because I know if I compete with him for
next Mouse no chance so this is how my
message it's up it's a challenge but
it's opportunity and it's the
opportunity for people like us
this world the most difficult of thing
is to convincing a successful people
wait tell him this is a great
opportunity to nananananana forget it
right I've been doing this for 30 years
but for people like us we're looking for
opportunities in order to survive so we
will do anything to be creative so this
is the message 30 years
it's opportunity for us it's a challenge
for those people who are 60 years old if
they're 60 years old
not discrimination but it is tough for
them rule number five respect your
competitors who's your most dangerous
competitor is it Amazon or is it
ten-second well people always think
compare us with Emma's Evers a great
company
I respect I've been seeing them from Al
tiny to that big and I think they will
continue to grow but we are different we
Amazon is an e-commerce company we are
not ecommerce company we enable other
people to do ecommerce we want to making
sure everybody can be Amazon so are you
saying $0.10 is the greater course they
are great company and you know it's it's
not easy to be that size within only
such less than 20 years so innovative
and so creative are so different on
social technology and they're basting
certainly in attention and they are
almost every way in China or respect of
course we compete but compete does not
mean I have to hate them don't hate your
competitors respect your competitors
learn from him but you know pony and I
we've been doing the charity together
the Nature Conservancy and protected the
or but we compete each other but when we
compete each other we should respect
each other I respect him I respect him
same rule number six see challenges as
opportunities this world today's of full
of challenges and opportunities 2,000
years ago full of challenges and
opportunities and I'm sure 2,000 years
later
full of challenges and opportunities
there's always it's depends on how you
look at
somebody look at this challenge as
opportunity young people we say there's
no opportunity I complain a lot when I
was young because I think Bill Gates
took odd opportunities for the Microsoft
Steve Jobs all these guys there's no job
there's no great big stuff left for us
but I think opportunity always lies in
the challenges always lies in the
complaints if you can solve the
challenge you have there you will be
successful
the big challenge you solve the big
problem of the the big opportunity you
have rule number seven my personal
favorite belief in the past 18 years
when I do internet in China we got a
criticism every day you know something
will you believe it a lot of people
criticize it but if you really believe
continue to do it improve it we were
rejected by more than 30 venture
capitalists but we are very optimistic
we believe in the future we believe in
Internet and we believe that if we do
not succeed
somebody will rule number eight surround
yourself with greatness how do I emote
to by incentive unlock by by our
colleagues you have to find the people
they can mobilize themselves it's
impossible to find two to encourage an
active person so the people your high
that people work together they they have
to be oh you cannot we have a 65,000 in
price now you cannot hire all of them
that positive but at least the people
work with me my management leadership
several areas they have to be positive
they have to know the incentive the
others because I cannot accept everybody
and making sure the culture so
I think it would be very painful for me
to talk to my vice president and he need
to be incentivized and mobilized every
time right this won't work if he is not
if he does not know how to incentivize
or mobilize his people it's better I
don't think he will be the vice
president they should be a good engineer
good designer but not good leader a good
leader should know how but not by only
money
most of people incentive lies or move on
not because you give them a lot of money
you give the respect just appreciation
and correct hard to fool advice when it
come to my meetings internal meetings
you have your shop because we we're not
like a lot of other Chinese company the
boss they ever listen take notes and
going down we are like a war room we
make this issue based on whose voice is
louder early days you know spider the
talk and then making sure everybody
speak up right so this is also a way of
mobile life and incentives there are a
lot of ways and different people have a
different way to send incentive rule
number nine live healthy I think life is
a journey you come to this world is to
enjoy the life to be happy and healthy
so the day when you leave the world and
say I'm happy in my life my health in
this life because if you're not healthy
you will not be happy so I believe happy
and healthy are the things the human
being always looking for
and I think next to 30 years because of
the technology people the life size is
gonna change a lot and people is gonna
live longer but we can live longer does
not necessarily live healthy so if
you're not healthy how can you be happy
if you live longer if you're not happy
why you live there and we'll number 10
the last one before the bonus clips have
fun
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now I've got some special jakmob bonus
clips for you but before that the
question of the day is do you have
enough fun in your business should
entrepreneurs have fun in their business
yes or no and why I'd love to hear from
you leave it down the comments below
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever you're
one where it is much love I'll see you
soon and enjoy the bonus clips
I found some great leaders in the world
they are always positive they never
complained others and never complain and
they they look at the things in a
different view like normal people so I
think people a my company they at the
beginning they don't like me because
I'll always think about ten years five
years and then after we working together
for three or five years they find out
who you are right then we got the credit
rating and as a CEO one of the jobs
where everybody's happy you have to see
the unhappy things when everybody's
unhappy you have to see the happy things
so leadership is nature but you have to
have a train and learn and I got my
leadership sub upgraded in Davos I see
so many well you know on the end to
financing how many people here know
about Ally pay Thank You Ally pace
decision was made here I was thinking
about Ally paid you know but I was not a
dare to launch a leap it because in
China if you do financing with
unlicensed you were being jailed at that
time so I say I went to the banks can't
help us do the e-commerce of transaction
no no no no banks would accept it so if
there will be no a leap in no financing
the e-commerce to go nowhere so I was
year 2004 I was here listen to a speech
by two state leaders about leadership
and this guy's leadership is about
responsibility you believe it but don't
be that people don't believe it but if
you think is so critical you should pay
any price to do it so that day change to
my mind I had a call back to my team say
let's launch it within one month if
somebody else go to the
Jill I go to the gym who would be the
second we'll follow me if I go you
continue and you go to the Jill you go
continue that was the called the
leadership determination and year 2004 I
made a decision here I called back and
now today the a leap a launched and it's
so big over you know 800 million people
today using a leap a bullet this is
called I was born a very normal family
and poor family six people
sure $7 a mouth we can only eat one
chicken a year was terrible
Nixon visit to my city 1972 China USA
signed Mao Zedong Nixon signed the
agreement so China become opened oh my
city Hauser was one of the first cities
that opened to the west we got a lot of
American tourists to visit my city what
he would do is he would befriend foreign
visitors who came to Hangzhou to walk
around the west lake there and I learned
English by being the free guide for tour
guide you know more than the language
Jack was learning about the culture the
things I learned from books from China
are so different from the things I
learned from the American visitors so I
start to think differently raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
value is that we believe that people
need passion
[Music]
not one drop of myself work depends on
your it's suppose to mean I don't ever
give up I'd have to be dead or
completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten most of success I have
a very special secret video for you
these are the individual clips that I
have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link in description for
details